aunque con la muerte de su madre se
convirtió automáticamente en rey el ex
príncipe de gales fue proclamado monarca
dos días después del fallecimiento de la
reina isabel en un evento constitucional
clave para la realeza británica en medio
de una transmisión que se veía desde
diferentes partes del mundo las cámaras
oficiales de la ceremonia captaron los
gestos de carlos tercero a sus ayudantes
las imágenes se finalizaron rápidamente
en redes sociales con miles de críticas
al jefe de estado pero este no fue el
único momento que reveló su incomodidad
después de visitar escocia para
acompañar el féretro de su madre el
monarca comenzó una gira por los cuatro
países del reino unido- en irlanda del
norte el rey se reunió con los líderes
políticos y asistió a algunos eventos
religiosos en honor a su madre allí el
nuevo rey volvió a ser portada de los
periódicos esta vez un bolígrafo
exasperó a su majestad y nuevamente el
acto solemne se vio empañado por
críticas a su comportamiento
el viernes el rey llegó a gales en lo
que fue la última a sus visitas a las
cuatro naciones del reino unido como
monarca a y una de sus simpatizantes le
regaló un bolígrafo en referencia a los
episodios previos el sábado el sucesor
de isabel se reunió con los primeros
ministros del reino incluidos los
líderes de canadá nueva zelanda y
australia pues con la ascensión al trono
ahora el rey es jefe de estado de otros
catorce países además del reino unido
el mismo día en un acierto para su
popularidad él y su hijo william el
príncipe de gales sorprendieron a la
multitud que hacía fila en el centro de
londres para visitar el ataúd de la
reina sus saludos y el contacto con la
gente fueron bien recibidos
[Aplausos]
y
esto fue totalmente inesperado estaba
haciendo fila desde la una de la mañana
y llegué aquí y no esperaba esto en
absoluto es algo fantástico que haya
sucedido esto y he tenido mucha suerte
de haberlo experimentado
con 73 años carlos tercero es el monarca
de mayor edad que ha tomado el trono en
la historia británica también fue el
primer heredero que no recibió educación
en casa y el primero en obtener un
título universitario y aunque no se ha
fijado fecha para su coronación ya se
habla de uno de los retos más grandes
que tendrá durante su reinado una ola de
posibles nuevas repúblicas de las ex
colonias británicas